[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
خلال الايام القادمه سنعيش مرحله تناطحات
جباهيه بين الشتويه والصيفيه الشتويه
تحاول الامساك في عناصر منظومه المناخيه
والصيفيه تدفعها واذا اشتدت المواجهه تولد
الغبار وهذه سمه موسم الربيع فلا ينفك من
جسد الشتاء الا بخشونه ارتفاع وانخفاض في
درجات الحراره موسم برد بياع الخبل عباته
غبار مطر صحوا موسم السرايات وموسم
المراويه فالتغيرات على مدار الساعه صرمت
حبالك بعد وصلك زينب والدهر فيه تغير
وتقلبه وكذاك وصل الغانيات فانه الم
ببلقعه وبرق
[تصفيق]
فالصيف بدا يقضم المناطق جنوبيه ويمشي شوي
شوي من هو له رايح رايح الا المناطق
الشماليه واول ايام العيد يفرض الصيف
سيطرته على كل المناطق وفي شهر مايو منتصف
شهر شوال تنتهي التقلبات الجويه ويعتدل
مزاج الجو احيانا بمزاج اكتب ولا حاجه
واحيان قبل اكتب الابيات تكتبني واحيانا
ما اعطيت كل الخلق وازعاجه واحيانا حتى
ضجيج الناس تعجبني
[موسيقى]